she's doing okay yeah she is she is able
to walk a few steps now which is nice
what happened what did you do what did
you do mike
what did you do mike it was a family
time
just literally like tripped up in the
street over like this and on the even
before it was
the most embarrassingly like simple
thing but yeah she's uh
she's doing it right now it's weird it
was weird not being able to go to any
with her that was strange because
obviously
is that a coveted precaution is that
what that was about yeah
but i didn't it didn't occur to me like
we went there you know got the uber
got over there got to the hospital and
like the guy on the
at the door of the hospital like doing
covert tests on people as they were
going in
was like oh you can't come in and it was
this moment of like
i'm an idiot of course i can't come in
that's yes no sorry i feel
just very british situation and feeling
absolutely embarrassed to have even
wasted
terribly sorry for your ridiculous
they're like putting they're like
putting a black bag over carrie's head
and dragging her off into an unmarked
band and you're like oh apologies
i should have known better yes you're
right um it is
like there there's people like you know
people that are having babies right now
and stuff like that you're like dads you
have to wait in the hall are like
no or what was the deal with cory's uh
corey's dad um cory barlog's dad uh
he's by himself yeah that's all i know
yeah i was like dude that is
sick with something oh yeah i mean i i
he has covered um was it covet i
couldn't i saw on twitter
yeah and then i couldn't remember
precisely um
yeah i mean okay i was like i could i'm
not gonna read corey's texts about his
dad
but uh basically he has coveted and it's
just it's just a bummer it's just a real
bummer things are still happening
um really sucks well i just like like
in my situation just the things that we
don't think about
it's it's affecting other people right
and then all of a sudden
it it like somehow tertiarily affects us
and like kerry doesn't have covet but
carrie has to go to the hospital
to to to fix a broken foot
and then that impacts mike is like
people don't it's like when the the the
writers strike happened there were so
many restaurants in burbank
that shut down because
that writer strike impacted shows that
were being produced
which then impacted all of the cafes and
the restaurants and the mom and pops
that supplied food to those so it was
like people don't realize that
all of this is connected we and and
that's why when people say we're all in
this together
that's not just like uh a glib sentiment
that's not being cavaliers being very
weird this will affect all of us it's
just like the fires in oregon right now
if you go outside i can't
i'm trying to figure we're gonna do a
traveler today it's like we can't go
outside man we're gonna get weird
indoors and like try to figure out some
stuff because everything
affects all of us so it's not just
something that you watch on you know the
news or on
you know your twitter feed it's like
this affects you unless you're in new
zealand and then you're fine
and then you're like running around we
got rid of the spiders and there's
snakes yeah there's no bloody smoke out
here
um yeah my dad going into hospital a
bunch this year was like super
nerve-wracking because of covert it was
just every time he had to go to hospital
and
he just got another surgery now on his
hand
and has been told that he's going to
have to have his finger removed
from like the second knuckle up and the
second knuckle down
no like that first who's gonna be his
whole finger and now it's from there up
and i'm like
they're gonna remove a part of my dad
like a very it's just been
it's just [ __ ] strange but every time
that he goes hospital i'm like please
people just
just please uh look off yourselves and
be aware of spreading sickness and
consider what other people are going
through who need to go to the hospital
like for what it's worth
my grandmother who died when i was
pretty young so i don't have
that many memories with her but she had
i think it was on her ring finger
he was missing from the knuckle up um
because when she had was a kid she was
you know
like growing up in the south you know
typical like
find a creek build a rope swing out over
it and the rope like
wraps around her wrapped around her
finger and literally pulled the end of
it off
so she her whole her whole life she was
missing
and my only memory of that it was that
she delighted in
like as a young kid being like hey do
you know this trick and then doing the
thing and then it's like
haha as a kid you're like
oh dear god how did you do that who are
you magic devil woman
a common thing for especially people in
texas who do rodeo that's not an
uncommon thing to be missing just a part
of your appendage
uh because of the same thing your your
um
your finger can get wrapped in the
latigo and if that horse yanks then
it'll just pull your finger out of this
this is an alternate uh universe of your
uh career had the whole of acting down
the road
yeah exactly i remember going to the
rodeo austin's family
sorry sorry you know okay so here [ __ ]
this
this person and we're transatlantic
bloody delay
is like genuinely i don't know
well basically whenever i start talking
i'm interrupting someone which i think
means it's like a two second delay or
something yeah but that's the brand
brother that's like what it's like this
is all about it's like it's all about
friends
that is this podcast is interruption
welcome to interruptions get on the
plane
sorry go on fly over here i would say
i'd do it
we did i would say
yeah well in an alternate universe we
were
we were hoping uh to do like whether
it's a gdc
or a or a dice of like
you know actual face to face
because ironically the only time we've
done this that way was
new york comic-con panel that started it
all
right well related i was gonna uh start
the show off
by saying this today mike you're okay
with us talking about carrie's broken
foot
that's staying in is that okay uh yeah
yeah that's cool yeah
or why wouldn't you be cool with that
yeah
the way in solidarity with carrie uh i
totally i i sprained my ankle uh last
year
so hard and it was literally the dumbest
thing it was the same
like it was one of those where you for
for as debilitating as it was you wish
there was
some heroic adventure uh for
what caused it and it was just literally
i was in nashville we were recording
um we were recording strings for
erica uh and was walking down the street
and there was like a little
one inch lift in the sidewalk where like
a potted plant was you know
on display in front of a restaurant or
something and just walking down and just
landed on it and rolled
and and it it rolled my ankle so hard
that
we were on our way to dinner so walk to
the restaurant and then the whole time
kept thinking like
i can feel this really swelling and i
just kept thinking ah you know
it's a sprained ankle like it the pain
will go away after
an hour and then you're fine and then i
remember cut to me at midnight lying in
bed and i'm
sweating and shaking and it was like i'm
gonna have to cut my [ __ ] foot off
um and uh finally they sent me they sent
me
like you know like whatever some
generic like advil or something from the
front desk just to try to
hold it at bay but still to this day
if i step on it weird it hurts uh like
yeah basically permanently damaged my
ankles and knees if you don't actually
deal with them we'll
screw you up for life they're real rude
um yeah but you know what we won't be
going to spraying
our ankles seattle because pax is online
this year
nailed it nailed it nailed it very well
we have a pax panel everyone it is on
monday the 14th of september from
11 15 a.m to 12 15 p.m
um totally online uh you can basically
find
which of twitch's twitch streams it is
going to be on i'll leave a link in the
description for all the details for that
um that's in pacific time but yeah it'll
basically be a live episode and we're
going to do our first q a
um so very excited for that i think
by the way i just want to point out has
anyone else seen me just kind of like
blink in and out of existence
what's the crap you've been glitching
yeah i always might be an ai that's
taken over troy's weapon maybe
yeah that's my theory i was super proud
i am broadcasting you broadcasting me
to you prepositions are weird guys i
don't believe in them
um from from my brand new spankin
pc i've joined the pc master race hi
coffee buddy i'm doing something weird
today are you doing a full lattes
mikey what are you doing there buddy i'm
being sponsored this week
oh very nice
pepsi no no youth oriented brand would
want my uh
my participation in folks you do look
better though troy like the the cat is
then you cameron you as well or is that
just
no it's just you're not supposed to
stream from the back like
nobody tells you that it's like don't do
that that's just i am it's working fine
yeah but yeah but you you have a barely
matched [ __ ] austin
yeah you also look like for in defense
of the mac
that's the shitty camera you also look
like hugh jackman in the fountain or is
oh i got to that too quickly for the
morning since i haven't introduced
everyone
hi i'm alana i'm in games media i'm
joined by austin wintry who is a video
game composer troy baker who is a video
game actor and mike bethel who is a
video game
director welcome to our show i don't
know what we're going to talk about this
week because when i was even looking at
stuff to talk about i was so
overwhelmed by choice that what i
thought i would start off with here is
um i had you guys back in june
apparently
guess for me what you thought the price
of the optical
playstation 5 is i'm really close i
don't remember
but i wanted to ask you again just to
see if they line up
after us getting you know this the
series s and x
price reveals if you are still going to
guess the same thing so mike
how much do you think the the optical
playstation i still think they're going
to go
high so xbox optical 500 right
uh xbox obstacle yes
dollar station you'll go like 607. i'm
going to say 650. i'm going to put it
right in the middle all right
there we go rubles what are we doing
what currency
dollars in dollars we're doing uh german
followers
pre-euro prussian francs we don't assume
that americans would know any other
currencies but dollars so we're not okay
i will have you know though that i keep
myself in
military time and also in uh
celsius as opposed to fahrenheit i do
currently 22 degrees and i do it as a
mental exercise i'm just trying to make
sure that i don't get like
weird brain as i get older so i'm like
learning french
and i do myself in celsius and people
pick on me all the time they're like
what is it in real temperatures i'm like
do you want to know that it's a 110 do
you want to know that
or do you like hearing that's like it's
43 degrees that sounds a little bit
better doesn't it that makes you want to
go outside doesn't it 43 is fine
110 yeah but you don't see you're going
outside 43.
no no one's going down it was it was
almost 50 it was it was 50 degrees last
last sunday you know that it was 50
degrees it was 121 degrees
in woodland hills oh yeah that was like
a state record
we did
in death valley famously the uh
close encounter valley of death uh
death valley recorded they said they
need to validate it but possibly the
highest uh earth surface temperature in
recorded history
isn't it just like death valley always
seeking validation
i know exactly it needs to take a look
at such a prima donna
it's the it's the trump of valleys
that's like i am the most death
i am the most tremendous nobody is more
definitely you're welcome we did it we
did the highest numbers very high number
but it's insane and the crazy thing was
that that's
that's you'd think that you'd think that
if it's 120 in
los angeles that death valley recording
you know an all-time temperature would
mean it's like 150 but it was like 130.
it was like how they're recording that
though what poor
schmuck is out there going i'm guessing
philip what's your and job
my stunt today i will endure this no i
isis
i suspect troy they have technology for
that uh
i have a feeling there might be why do
you think i had the balloons
maybe it's david
so when we the optical drive included is
going to go
high because i think they're definitely
wanting to push everything to their
online services so i think they're going
to go 299
for just the digital version only i
think they're but mike's right they're
going to go 4.99
um with i said 600 650. you did
i definitely think that that dustless
drive will be more expensive but uh troy
sorry cheaper no no no i do mean that i
am right i do mean i think it'll be more
expensive than 299.
i think that their diskless drive
will probably be 3.99 i think they're
going to ge
have they ever launched and then quickly
dropped like did a holiday thing where
it's like 3.99 and i'm trying to
remember what south park did because
that's honestly
my thank you steve or thank you austin
uh steve
i don't know where that came from steve
ulster it's it's a wrestling thing
nice you love wrestling i don't feel
well
thank you steven troy and i have bonded
extensively over
wwe that is that is
ah he's going to go for the suplex the
double suplex that's a wonderful move
isn't it austin
yes it's a wonderful night here for the
that's a great bit by the way we should
write that
um austin steve steve stone called
steven so what do you think austin's one
of my best friends his name is steve
yes that's testament but you're like
mousing over my zoom window to make the
name show up
oh [ __ ]
who's that guy who's always moving um my
flower i remember my i think i
said 500 before um i honestly don't
remember but that that was my instinct
today
and it still feels pretty right it still
feels like that's a pretty good number i
think
mike you know i have a feeling is
is that's probably going to be it it's
going to skew on the higher but i i feel
like almost optimistically 500 is a
pretty palatable number
i think especially given that that it's
not a given that it would need to have
the drive so i you know because they
obviously
i think xbox is exerting a downward
price pressure on them
uh and so do you think that works though
i do not
believe that at these companies like i
don't believe that sony's gonna be like
well what's
caught a hundred bucks like it happened
last time remember that's not
bull but it's not but it's not a matter
or was it just announced that way
it's not a matter of them saying that
though they don't just they don't just
say
like let's just cut like it's it it
would be a
let's review our manufacturing process
let's review like are there ways to
bring this price down because our
competitor
is going to kill us on that front like
so i actually i think you i think the
opposite of what you're saying is true
like that's my i'm probably gonna be
proven wrong by the time this video goes
up right
can't wait what i'm saying i actually
think the
i think well i think the play for
playstation is not is to actually go up
i think that's i mean that's where
they're thinking to be like the premium
brand
it's value that's the place that's the
field that's wide open right now because
if you look at it you've got switch
which is doing its own thing over here
and he's having a great time and lots of
people love it
xbox is definitely positioning itself as
like not the value console but like like
the console that can offer a lot of
value and specifically with those kind
of subscription models it's a really
interesting different business model for
a concert i like the semantics of that
it's not the value console but it is the
console that can offer a lot of value
but that's the difference right i don't
know if the same quantitation is true
it's like value
they're going for your for the parent
who wants to like i'm going to pay x
month
x x x a month in subscription and my kid
is going to have lots of rolling content
that's that's the play they're making
to me playstation it's time to become
the iphone it's time to become like the
luxury
we this isn't just a games console this
is a playstation you know i think like
that's the angle from marketing purely
from marketing point of view that seems
like
if i was if i was in that room i would
probably be the one saying maybe we need
to say this is a luxury device and push
in that direction
and that's i don't know i don't know if
that's true i don't know how consumers
would react to that but it feels like
a space because they're differentiating
a lot more this is our console war
i think didn't elana am i stealing this
from a video from you i feel like i saw
you make this point it's not really
a direct competition they're just very
different now all the consoles
my take is you may have yeah because i
feel like i say i think i've stolen this
from you because i think it's true
it keeps happening though let me just
eric in the comments people credit me
with like
most of what you say and i'll be like
mike he just backed up the point that i
made
i think that might be some kind of
institutional problem in the world
in this next generation of console wars
it's virtually impossible to quantify
because they're fighting different
fights
um if we've previously gone on who has
sold the most hardware
i don't think you can even qualify the
success of which company is winning i
hate but i hate all of this but
you can't even really do that anymore
because playstation is trying to sell
playstations and xbox is trying to sell
subscriptions so
they are just doing completely different
things at this point yeah
mike that's a fascinating i hadn't
thought about that sorry troy i'm
distracted by your brilliant joke i
apologize yeah
it's very good it's it's undercutting
your points have you noticed the joke
yet
listen guys i want to make a very
serious comment don't look at my name
my name's not important names are not
important names are just a i missed
integrated systems
they're philosophical i thought i
thought you were about podcasts i
thought you were referring
i thought you were you were saying the
joke was that he instantly says
no mike i agree after alana finishes uh
articulating this point
i think that's very this is chess right
here
you gotta get your zoom game up guys who
showed troy where that button was this
is why
so honestly it's people within my people
within
our little community we do our little
things on saturday and sunday we do our
movie screen on saturday and are prompt
on sunday and people just they're
they're
their name game is high and i'm like i
got to step it up um
i feel like we've gone analog with
instead of like tick-tock and digital
content it's now like what can i do with
with
like you know this naming system anyway
um i didn't think about because what i
was thinking was like
again kind of going back to the fact
that all of these things are connected
right just in the same way that
that the way that you now go to urgent
care or whatever
um is effective because of kova even
though you may not be directly impacted
by covet
i feel like this console generation
launch is going it already has been
affected by code by the the titles that
have been pushed
the movies that have been pushed um
but the fact of going all right mom and
dad
or all right people that are upwardly
mobile and have the money to spend on
this
we understand that you've probably been
impacted by this economically because
it's been global it's not just like a
certain
group of people so we can kind of just
mitigate and disenfranchise those people
but globally people have been impacted
from an
economic standpoint um so instead of
gouging you and making this be more
expensive
we want to drive the cost down and make
this more um
palatable and a more affordable
expenditure but i hadn't thought about
the angle of like and the way that we're
going to do that
is by creating this whole new system
just like you've been
you know accustomed to netflix and
amazon and hulu and disney plus and
everything else
now you're not going to pay 60 bucks for
a game now you like to pay
15 bucks a month that's a lot better
isn't it even though most people
typically what's that what's the
standard it's like most people buy four
games a year or five games a year
something like that
so that that hits that mark right so
four months of those people is 60 bucks
but you're actually getting three times
that amount for people who are
subscribers because their attrition is
going to be super low
i have not played my xbox
in two years but i still have my goal
pass
we just lost half our subscribers
the fanboys there's no fanboys for xbox
comments
um you're welcome guys i'm just stirring
that i feel like this show is eating
itself now like yes
we've arrived 29 episodes later
so we can go back to monthly it's not so
instead of saying like it's
it's a it's a luxury thing i think being
able to go is like we are saving you
money it just there's a little bit more
of an upfront cost but it will be worth
it in the long run
um and i mean clearly people have been
able to do that by saying like apple tv
is like yeah you have to spend a little
bit up front
um but you'll be able to have access to
all of this content so
i think that that's that's um that's a
wise thing maybe maybe i am wrong maybe
they're not going to go
299 maybe they will go higher because
they'll be like
but on that on the i don't know man i
still think we're one generation away
from that because we're not full
subscription yet we're still
box title you know hard costs we are
close
seem to want to take us there yeah or
even doing it with the hardware right
like they literally you don't
you don't need to buy an xbox you can
just subscribe to an xbox right
and honestly the model of the hard disk
is such an antiquated things like we
haven't been doing
software that way for a decade what i
mean was the last time you had to go and
buy
a box set of office or
pro tools or anything i still remember
the excitement when i went to microsoft
hq once and i went in the microsoft shop
i was a very cool
i'm very cool guy very and they have
like their staff
with the staff discount you could get
office for like 50 off troy it was
pretty magical
um so the reason that i i also for the
record
i said 450 mike you've gone more
expensive you've you've gone up from 550
to 650
austin and troy you stay the same i
think i said 450 to make this
interesting but i feel like
it probably is going to be 5.99 um is
what i
think and then i think the diskless
version
will be maybe 3.99 even maybe 4.99
because the
the xbox series s the 299 console
has more taken out of it than just that
disk drive
uh it will it won't run at 4k so it is a
next-gen box but it is also lower
resolution
that's how they made it so cheap and i
don't think playstation is going to do
that
they are just going to remove that disk
drive and then everything else will be
the same so
very interesting to see how much that
ends up mattering to players like if
people buy
in droves a thing that can't support 4k
it'll be an interesting
testament to that not just that not
mattering to people as much as we think
it does
but mike to devs does that would that
piss you off you're like we
we did all of this work to make sure
that our game will run
in 4k at 60p or 60 frames is that gonna
be we'd be like and we didn't have to do
it or do you always have to dev for the
do you always dab for the best or do you
dev for the way wait can i just
can i just point out there's two
different questions in there it's two
different
uh steve please uh we'll be with you hi
nice to meet you all um there are uh
you're asking you're asking basically
you know do we do it because we have to
but also would it be a massive bummer to
do that knowing that they won't see the
results of that i feel like that's two
different things i'd like to hear the
answer to
please steve's right steve out teacher
right
stephen thank you steve i mean honestly
most developers would just love a
consistent platform we could ship
to and we didn't have to worry about
references like that's i mean every dev
basically wants
everyone to own you know a 16x9 monitor
at this resolution with this hardware
plugged into it because essentially
everything is a variation and like
i have to with pc versions of games like
i need to support super wide
i i remember when we were doing when we
were finishing up john wick
and we you know obviously a bigger
project it had massive qa process
and we were getting from the qa team
like uh bugs where
this game uh the text didn't render well
at 640 by 480 four by three resolutions
and there was this moment in the team of
like does anyone realistically still
play a pc game at
480p and and ultimately we decided hey
probably someone does we'll do what we
can to kind of help them and support
them but
like yeah no this is game developments
development's frustrating as hell from
this level
even the fact that on modern console
games you you sometimes have that screen
where you have to like
choose where the edges of your screen
are and by the way this was
this setup is perfect for this mine that
great the fact that that still is a
thing because what that means is when
you're designing ui
you're basically kind of think of it
like left aligning or right aligning
text in a word processor
you're having to do that scale to
account for all these multitudes of
different situations
forget about it if you're on like a
mobile phone and you don't know what the
resolution of that screen is what the
ratio of that screen is you have to
really cater for it so that's part of
the artistry of
video game ui is that no one really
knows about is making everything
scale and work at every different
resolution there's an art to it and it's
it's
it's really kind of interesting to work
on and i do a lot of that work on our
projects because it's
it is interesting but it is kind of
thankless no one cares as long as it
looks good on their monitor it's not
like people are downloading your game
and playing on 10 different monitors to
see
all of the brilliant ways you've you've
made it work across the board
with accessibility options too it's like
having to consider various disabilities
people who are hard of hearing people
who are blind like how to
let every single person play a video
game and consider all of those things
is you're right a massive thankless task
that requires so much work but i mean is
it i don't imagine that
making something work for 4k and 1080 is
difficult
but again i don't know anything like
it's not it's not it's not difficult
it's it's just kind of it can be tricky
in terms of
just things like aliasing on fonts like
so um
the way fonts are smoothed on the on
desktop i know you know it's a lineup
but like the the smoothness smoothing
and all that stuff
the way you would approach around 1080p
versus a 4k
um and the expectation from players of
course is that if they've got a 4k
console they want
all of the all the images in the ui to
be 4k
and smooth and clean i remember i saw a
review of the you the tony hawks
remaster uh recently that commended like
oh it's a 4k
ui and it's this kind of this this stuff
does matter to the player so yeah you
have to just cater to that
upper end so basically what you're
always trying to do in game development
especially console game development is
you're trying to
you're targeting the highest rares but
you're trying not to leave anyone behind
because you know people aren't going to
have the the bad setups
makes me the naf tv there are still
people playing
modern games on like four by three
actually i don't know
when was four by three deprecated i
think i feel like ps4 actually supports
four by three
i mean it might be a requirement on a
projector that was four by three
oh really yeah so you're still catering
to all of this stuff like it's come up a
few times with our games that we've had
it reminds me i can't remember the
situation with ps4 i can't remember but
it has to be such a
small amount can you not just mitigate
that and go this game will not run 4-3
right you've been on the internet troy
right you've encountered the internet
yeah yeah then you can't go to the
audience to go you guys can't wear it
it reminds me of the opposite does that
my guess is
do those sentiments equate to a loss of
sales you may get
vitriol on on reddit but will that will
that
impact theoretically it would be a loss
of sales from like the contingent to
people that literally can't play the
game right
yeah but if that's such a small
percentage it's really hard to ever draw
a line between like
online reaction and sales but but true
last of us part we try not to upset
people right you know
you are giving me flashbacks though to
the uh when crisis came out and the big
story around it was that
it it basically can't run on any current
pc
it's full specs it was like yeah we've
made a game for the future
you need you need like the hal 9000 to
run this thing
um and it was interesting how that was
its own
it's kind of leaning the other direction
of you know that's pc versus console
right so with pc
the player there's a certain amount of
like um like a maker mentality with pc
gamers that they want
they want to poke around they want to
test things they want to play with the
settings you know that's part of the
fun of the hobby for them whereas
console players just do not want any of
that
or at least um i guess more importantly
from my perspective
the console companies don't think their
players want that stuff
so they'll offer so you have these these
these part of the point of a console
right i don't want to crack my console
open i don't want to be i don't want to
have to add a peripheral to it if i
don't have to but my pc
i'm like i feel like i want to get it
it's like the difference between owning
like a ferrari
yeah and and like get like an extra 0.1
of a frame per second and all this stuff
it's not necessarily that it's just i
just want to raytrace bro
have you seen speaking of crisis and
you've seen that the yeah
the uh the crisis remastered on console
is gonna have ray tracing
yeah i think the ps i think that mike
because i think that's an interesting
one too
um is baffling to me how
is that crisis how does crisis really
look so bad it's going to be my question
yeah like it almost looked worse than
the original crisis
um and i know that like if you look at
the history of crytek like that whole
thing is a mess but
that game was supposed to come out i
believe in june or july and they pushed
it because the reception of the trailer
was so bad that they were like
everyone was like i'd prefer to just
play crisis one that it's now coming i
mean i missed all of that
what were there what were the complaints
about the aesthetics and they just
looked
it doesn't it just yeah it just looks
atrocious it's like muddy the lighting's
really poor everything looks really flat
this
the textures are uh so obviously
repeated
uh it just well that's fascinating it's
like i just don't understand so there's
a few i i'm completely unaware of that
entire conversation but
like speaking as if i know what i'm
talking about like there's definitely
all well one of the things that really
pull it off with these
that's right yeah this this accent has
gotten me further in the industry than
any of the skills i actually prefer
you know what i didn't believe your
pitch but your accent your english
is your english side really does
convince me of this it's funny
um but like first of all with halo what
was interesting with the halo reaction
recently because it's a negative
reaction in similar vein
on that one that one seems to have been
that they just
they just chose a poor time of day from
a lighting perspective in that demo
to some extent there are certain issues
where you know the stuff that players
expect to look good
uh you know the stuff the signifiers to
players of this is a really
great rendering system um are not served
by like
what they showed which was like an
overcast day in
a boring weather cycle so everything
looked a bit flat so i wonder if that
was maybe with christ if it's got some
kind of environmental
kind of time of day stuff maybe that was
unfortunate
the other thing that we've we've
contended with and is fascinating
and i'm sure there are side-by-side
comparisons that prove why i'm about to
say completely wrong in the case of
crisis but it's a really interesting
phenomenon
is your memory of games makes them look
so much better than they actually did
all the time and it's always really fun
to contend with
we had it with volume we released which
was a stealth game
and it kind of looks it kind of looks a
bit basically it was a it was a bit
melky side vr missions like we knew we
were making it was fine
um and we got in reviews people would
say we're crediting us with copying
uh you know features that from from the
original uh mel design vr missions
that were not in metal gear solid vr
missions they were kind of quality of
life stuff we'd done
um in terms of vision cones from the
enemies and stuff and they were
literally describing these features they
remembered from
from metal gear vr missions that were
not in it that but you remember these
you remember games as having mechanics
and aesthetic qualities that they simply
didn't put the mandela effect rain fills
in the gaps
yeah it's really interesting and i i
think sometimes with remasters it's a
really interesting thing where you're
you're not actually competing with the
original game
you're competing with how people
remember that game that they played when
they were a kid and were excited by and
all this stuff
now i'm sure in this case they're
probably comparison videos that prove
everything i'm saying is
it's not true but like it's a more
generalized kind of interesting thing no
but that's
useful as a study of the human brain
that is unquestionably true
because we we don't we don't our brains
are not actually hard drives like
they we we don't just we don't just
dock like visuals and and you know like
little quick time videos basically in
our
in our head we we basically leave behind
the sort of formula needed to
reconstruct an event and it's going to
be heavily
subjectively influenced by not just what
was going on
at the time our emotional state all that
kind of thing but our current emotional
state and we'll recolor
everything which is why it's baffling i
come across this all the time
just as part of my general nerdiness for
things like epistemology where
uh the fact that the criminal justice
system at least in the us
puts such a huge primacy on eyewitness
testimony when it is
by far the most unreliable form of
testimony that could possibly exist
over and over and over i mean how many
times
you know you have things like the um the
um
um i'm blanking on the name of it um
it might be the innocence project but
there's a there's a handful of
uh uh criminal justice non-profits that
basically are going back
and you know there are cases where
people have been in jail for 10
20 30 years basically because somebody
pointed at them and said you did it
and uh they're able to in this part
blows my mind they're somehow able to
use dna testing still to this day i've
never understood how that's possible but
there will be like some
fragment of evidence somewhere that
they'll be able to do dna testing and
exonerate
this person all this time later despite
someone and the thing is
i don't think in most cases that people
have this malicious intent to like lie
and point the finger at somebody
they just don't get it right and we just
assume
i mean here's a personal example of one
of my favorite
favorites of these i uh two thousand
and sixteen seventeen something
like troy's
i'm listening i am it's like he's he's
got his own little show over there i
know he's gonna say this is where
this is we're really we're really
sticking it to those spotify
uh folks today um
the um so i was in new york and i saw
hamilton
um on broadway and i had not i had i had
been hearing about it you know this was
obviously
you know it was it was already
thoroughly a known entity at that point
but it was still relatively early in its
takeover of the world
and i had a friend who um
who had been advocating for it but i had
never listened to one note of music i
i had i had intentionally said you know
i know i'm going to be in new york
i'll i'll see it live as a as a kind of
virginal experience without walking in
having listened to the album a million
times like a lot of other
people and so i remember the act one
closer is this big show stopper
uh called non-stop and i
i see it and the the sort of recurring
um
line of the song is um
eliza asking why are you always writing
like you're running out of time
and as someone i was i was at the tail
end of a pretty
um [ __ ] up period of my life
and obviously you know i had talked here
before about my father and that was
still relatively recent and there were a
lot of things that were
at play in me emotionally and so i see
this show and i'm like i'm
like crying and just i'm blown away and
think it's just the most amazing feat of
creativity and
and of songwriting and narrative in one
incredible alchemy together and just
thought this is this is utterly
mind-blowing i can't believe
that one person essentially just hatched
this so single-handedly
and so i was telling people for weeks
after i said there's this amazing song
halfway through that has this most
beautiful succinct
study of our mortality where she says
why do you always write like you're
running out of time
and he says because i am and i was this
amazing
just it cuts straight to it in so few
words and i'm telling everyone i know
about how
brilliant the song is then i finally go
to listen to the album
and he never says that i had completely
made it up and projected and i could
hear it
with certainty i could hear it musically
i could hear it sung
wow uh and and then i realized that she
says what he was right like you're
running out of time and then the song
just moves on
and i i i literally i had told everyone
i know about those
lyrics yeah and so yeah it's one of
those like
if ever if if
[ __ ] the bookshelf returns
the lyrics i mean i certainly had that
uh with the
rare replay like in my head banjo
kazooie looks exactly like it looks in
rare replay but then you see actual
footage of banjo-kazooie and i'm like go
what has happened to you like it's
terrible it's like goldeneye 64. when
you see the close-ups of the faces
and my memory in my memory like is sean
bean
and then you look and it's just this
horrible monster you're like
uh you know my god yeah it's super
interesting how that stuff happens how
oh yeah you basically just can't trust
human memory whatsoever and you
individual people do things differently
too like some people will remember based
on what emotion they were feeling at the
time
other people will remember based on what
they catalogued at the time so you can
also have people who
remember based primarily on sensors like
i think all that stuff's really
interesting and i learned a bunch about
it because
i probably mentioned this before but
because of the way that we remember vr
so humans because your brain
subconsciously thinks that what's
happening in vr is real you will
remember a vr location or experience to
the same extent that you would remember
it if it had actually happened to you or
if it was in the real world
or if you're playing a video game you
want so like sitting down playing one in
your living room so if i'm gonna
go through the house in resident evil 7
and i'm playing it
on my tv in my living room i'm not going
to remember it half as well as i would
if i were doing it in vr
because again my brain is like i need to
remember this because this is a real
location i'm at even though it's not and
i just think the fact that
we're tricking our brains into thinking
things are real which is the same reason
vr motion sickness occurs is because
your body is like why am i not moving in
the way that the images are moving
like the world is moving must have been
poisoned it's so cool
i i'll never forget what i was i was
hold on
what is that what that is yeah it's your
body when your body
think when your body's getting uh
contrasting information it believes that
it must have been poisoned
and therefore tries to vomit in order to
expel the poison
that's where motion sickness comes from
as well yep
i've never seen a dozen i'm so excited
about
right now this is blowing my mind did
look like a kid that was very cute troy
that's beautiful it's charming it's
lovely
i mean isn't that it makes sense it's
the same reason why you get motion sick
on a
on a boat because you're basically your
brain is trying to reconcile why
the world your your sense of of like
the the downward pull of gravity is at
odds with where you think you make some
bad berries or something yeah
i just thought that was simple as like
look the the fluid that's in your
cochlea or whatever in your inner ear
when it shifts that that way it creates
just this chemical reaction i didn't
know that there was actually some form
of like evolutionary
programmed response poison
again why i think vr is so cool it's we
we have provably tricked our brains and
i can't think of another instance of
something doing that where
we are blatantly tricking
our senses into thinking we're doing
something that we're not
and it's just your subconscious just has
absolutely no idea even if you
consciously know what's happening and
you can't override it
the fact that i can't be like no stupid
brain it's vr stop making me vomit when
i play minecraft
is just fascinating like we're just
manipulating ourselves for entertainment
you can argue that's all entertainment
that's true that's true
i i i've always struggled with vr
because i find that i am really
susceptible to that motion sickness
and i remember once when we were working
on
um deformers i was down at ready at dawn
and they showed me like a very early
prototype of
um of lone echo and
this was it was basically a tech demo
still at this point i mean this was this
was years ago
and they said you know all right put it
on put on put on the oculus and they're
like
you know i've got the i've got the
little handles and i'm seeing my
i'm seeing you know they're like okay
push off against this wall and just see
how naturally you can kind of
swivel around and grab at floating in
zero gravity you know grab the opposite
the opposite wall and then like climb
along a ladder and just move
in complete and total 360 degree zero
gravity
and then i remember um i think it was
rue
uh or dana who was walking me through it
where where i i go to the
uh the like ladder and they say now look
over your shoulder and i look and
there's like a little
porta i mean i'm in like a big spherical
kind of you know like um the danger room
in x-men like in this big
chamber that's just kind of like a
sphere and uh or cerebro
rather um and i um i'm holding this
ladder and they say now when you look
over your shoulder and there's a little
portal
can you can you aim well enough to just
push off
and drift like through the portal to the
exterior of the ship
and this whole time you've been in like
a pretty tight narrow space
and so i push and i manage to hit the
target and i come out and i
and i just go out in open space and i'm
over
saturn and i instantly started sweating
yeah and like but it was like it was
like a religious experience it was one
of those where it was the first time i
thought vr is a thing this is not a
gimmick like
i genuinely felt like a lifelong
ambition to
drift amongst the stars was realized as
realistically as i was ever gonna and
the funny thing is this was a tech demo
if i went back and looked at like
playback capture of what i was looking
it was probably nothing compared to
where it's at now because even you know
radio dawn in particular are so stickler
for incredible visuals but this was
i was so blown away at how
just real it felt and and and visceral
it was
unbelievable experience and also for for
that as well the first time that i
played it i was and my body
was convinced it was real that's the
whole point of why i brought up is like
that
the
sweat made me feel like i'm i'm in a
beautiful place
but i'm not necessarily 100 safe right
now because i am floating in space right
now
i mean it was just one of those anyway
go ahead troy i um i had done some vr
before and the same thing i was like
typically it's like sit down and like
you're in a mech or whatever and you
have to turn around and that's where i
would be like
that that would that would have an
adverse response or a reverse reaction
to me but
the the thing with lone echo is they
handed me a controller and so i was like
using a controller
and then they said they haven't released
these yet but here are some
actual um hand controls that they're
going to have and they actually gave me
what everybody's has for
oculus now and for everything yeah it
was the same thing where your fingers
move right yeah but for this before it
was like
you know x does this why does this and i
was like okay
and so i'm kind of maybe does this i was
like got it so i'm moving and i was very
like playing like a game the second they
put those in my hands i
immediately started just like it
instantly how i
i had like a haptic tangible feel
it was the first game i was like how
long was i in there like five minutes or
like
25 minutes the tape ran for 18 hours
it came out and the developers all had
beards yeah that was like so i actually
came out and
there was like smoking craters and no
one had been around for ages guys this
game
guys guys what's charlton heston doing
here
why do you look like a monkey it's the
opening of 28 days later
it was it was such a cool experience i i
that that to me
but the reason why it works is because
there it's interesting that that austin
had that experience because for me
it was the traversal is the biggest
thing to try
to to tackle with with vr because that's
what makes us feel like my legs aren't
moving but i see that i'm
so if you like play like um honor and
blood or whatever it is or blood and
honor
blood and truth thank you you know you
did the point and warp and point and
warp and stuff it's it's a
it's a bigger bias yeah
but it's it's the difference between
like i'm moving through the world and of
course i don't feel myself moving
because i'm in zero g it was just the
greatest like oh this is how we
tackle traversal in this is a great
company like
commercial for lone echo star
and who does who's starring in that game
i wonder
oh i don't know could be anyone
her name is
[Laughter]
she's actually really quite good i have
about five minutes because i gotta go to
daddy duty day
yeah today i gotta go full daddy duty
which sounds
i never thought that i would say that
and as a man of my farts would be like
and i could just see alana like trying
to figure out
you know what are we gonna call this um
i do think that all the time uh every
episode
um and then i'm on a live stream and i
title it
because i'm working while titling it and
i'm like that was to why did i do any of
that
and it's just a whole mess but i'll
figure it out i'll figure it out i would
just like you guys to know that uh
liverpool are currently
3-2 um up to leads
uh just in case you were wondering i
don't want to get into politics
without any information i have no idea
they're they're uh
there there is a lot that i'm maybe on
at our pax
um live show uh that we can get into
because i'm so
there's a lot that's been going on i'm
so curious to hear your respective takes
on
i did watch the dune trailer for what
it's worth i do i do want to close out
talking about that austin
sorry steve stephen with the ph
by the way
if you're gonna it's stefan actually uh
um
yeah in real time uh
yeah i mean i am a big fan of that
director
danny valeneuv he he that guy has proven
himself to be quite the
quite the what has he done prior to this
was blade runner uh
2049 or whatever 90210 uh
and um and um and then before that was
arrival
and sicario and prisoners
there you go the ambition of that guy as
a filmmaker and just the production
design like just the
the the the unbelievable the first time
i saw a trailer for arrival
where you just see those wide shots of
the ships just floating and it's like a
painting i mean it
the guy the the but obviously it's not
the director alone it's working with
incredible cinematographers and art
directors and people like that
production designers but still as the as
the vision driving it because you can
really see the consistency it's like
ridley scott also where it's just
you can make the worst film but it looks
amazing
and but this one i i have it makes me
want to go reread dude i haven't read it
again
i haven't read it since i was a kid um
but it really looks like and and seeing
all my
die hard you know dune obsessed
you know nerd friends be like holy [ __ ]
finally i feel
i feel like finally got what it deserved
yeah i feel like dune
is the uh cinematic equivalent to rush
like if you're really into rush you're
probably gonna like dune
um i never
there's the title of today's episode
i've never read the book
um i know that the the story behind the
story of making dune and how it was
originally um you know
what was the person that actually
created it but then actually franklin
her frank herbert
for perfect the author you mean yeah
yeah um and like he thought he was going
to do the movie and then no
that didn't happen um and and so like
gerowsky as well
was it not i'm saying i'm butchering
that name jodowowski or
there's a movie about the making of the
dune movie that never got made
oh wow yeah that's what it is um
and then i you know i i was like oh but
when
i saw a star trek i was like that's the
guy from dune
that's uh why do they all have blue eyes
i
i this is this is how maybe per perhaps
shallow i am
i was like ah another reboot do we need
to
i was like okay here's the point in the
trailer was like this could have been a
trailer for
anything it's the same kind of beats and
then they got me with the pink floyd
they got me with the pink floyd man that
is one of the best
opus like that that specifically off
dark side of the moon
every time every time gives me chills it
is just such a
wonderfully orchestrated arranged
written impactful especially listening
in context of the entire record
and somehow they managed to
imbue that that trailer with all of that
ethos from that song
and what an interesting choice the
second time that a trailer has surprised
me with the use of a song of going
that's not a misappropriation like you
what you did
you know what never fails to amaze me is
that i see people
always still to this day i thought that
the kind of general media literacy had
reached a point where people understood
that
marketing teams are the ones making
those decisions and like
maybe from for a director like that he
probably is involved and there's
obviously kind of
history there with pink floyd so it's
like it makes sense but
but uh is there there but they're
yeah isn't there um uh a connection
um i mean weren't they involved in the
movie i was talking about that kind of
the one that never got made
is that what was that then is that what
it was
david lynch no because the david lynch
was very famously um
wasn't that tangerine dream yes yeah i
know it was qui
i think it was queen with the one i'm
talking about that sounds right i need
to watch that
ah okay yeah i might be having my wires
crossed but but either way
the the point the point um
notwithstanding that um marketing
departments are who make these trailers
like
like third-party groups and on a film
like this the director is
certainly going to be involved i would
think but there's no like
aggressively third party like rooster
teeth has made video game trailers
yeah like nothing to do with anything
we've ever worked on
like rooster teeth has cut video game
trailers as like a contract studio like
it's so
separate that's
the games trailers were done by the same
house that does the movies and those
they they're doing all the avengers
trailers and everything so you're kind
of yeah visiting like those offices
there are literally like
amazing boutique studios in hollywood
that are just just
trailer houses trailer park trailer park
is one of them
it is an it is an art form it's like we
have and
they used to only be like a finite
amount of space and now they're like
well they're four or five minutes seven
minutes
long for these with these epic trailers
for these you know huge movies
so it's like how do we to direct a
trailer in the same way that if you
actually look at like a previously on
is a very unique skill set to be able to
communicate a lot of information to the
viewer
and onboard them very quickly so that's
why
some of the best directors came from
commercials because
um how do you you have 30 seconds to
tell a story
and every second every frame
yeah music video's the same way but
there's to me music video is different
because a music video is all about
matching visuals to a a an established
rhythm
because the music music videos are
actually a lot easier because
your cuts are predetermined for you
right the
the rhythm of your shots that of your
editing is is laid out because you want
to make sure that you're doing
everything with the
you know one in the three of the of the
kick or the two and the four of the
snare or when the
guitars come in that's going to change
your shot but actually being able to go
in a commercial is like i need to tell a
story in 30 seconds and
every second i have i have a second
to tell this story and a second to tell
this story so that
30 30 shots is all i have it's brilliant
to be able to convey that
editing is is uh you know i've been
editing professionally and i'm certainly
not
you know trailer levels of skill but um
i've been editing professionally for
it's probably six years now
did a lot of editing at ign and video
editing is is a
really interesting yeah very very unique
to everything else that i do in a way
that
if it's good same as there's a lot of
things we've discussed here nobody
notices
so if something isn't well edited no one
has any idea um there's some great
articles no sorry i wanna go ahead i was
just gonna say like even editing a
gameplay from an hour down to
ten minutes which is something i do
frequently is a math of how do i make
sure
the the narrative of what is happening
in this is consistent how do i minimize
crosstalk if other people are talking
but make sure that their points are
still
getting across what do you cut to make
sure that funny things are
funny like often it's just a matter of
if you even trim one second
after a joke earlier than you think you
should it's funnier
like there's just so many pieces moving
of like okay well i need to keep that
cut scene in
because that sets up this next bit that
happens but we don't want too much
cutscene because then that's too much of
this content and we're talking over it
like
it's really like this ongoing constant
puzzle i really enjoy it
editing there's a there's a twitter i
recently discovered uh
that's called like perfectly cut screams
or something like that that is one of
the funniest [ __ ] things i've ever
seen in my life where it's literally
like
you know a guy in his car with a cup of
coffee and then he drops it and it
starts again it goes
and then it just cuts and it's just like
every time it's [ __ ] hilarious
and uh there's a million of them and i
just yeah to me if you want
super power ben schwartz says and then
on this i'm gonna have to go but ben
schwartz does this great thing he had a
the guy who can't come in on to us long
at the right time
and it's just it's it's wonderfully cut
and he's just it's
it's just a like almost like a tick tock
or instagram whatever
um i think his his uh handles rejected
jokes but if you look
it's just him playing along with
somebody with an acoustic and he's
trying to like come in on like
songs that everybody knows and he just
can't come in on the right and his
friends are going
no just wait no like he does one with
john mayer and john
mitchell but he's doing in such earnest
and everybody knows that guy that's just
really going for it and you couldn't be
worse
on ben schwartz's twitter somewhere yeah
it's also as an instagram binge schwartz
is really really talented and he's a
yeah
he's a nice guy um at least everything
that i've i've seen i could be wrong the
guy could be just a deplorable human
being but everything that i've seen
he does a good job messaging nice guys
yes
marketing is great um have fun
tell you know titling this alana maybe
it's the ben schwartz episode that's
what it is
it's like look we're saving all of our
good stuff for next week
yeah we will uh i like the idea of the
time code being literally the last
seconds of the show
when people post the announcements
playstation it's a tough one but yeah so
just a reminder pax panel is
on monday 11 15 a.m next week's episode
in a day
yeah pretty much it's weird i'll leave a
link in the description to details but
if you can't catch it live
the show will basically air exactly the
same as always so we'll still i'll still
record the pax panel and have it up on
friday so
that is will that include the q a is
there a restriction on us uh
don't believe this there pax isn't like
gonna
is it also is it is it totally it's just
on twitch
uh like it's it's there's no there's no
like tickets uh kind of thing the way
paxton normally
no totally free pass to watch all the
panels which i think is a is a plus
people are getting to see us for free
that seems they should pay it seems like
we're we're yeah pack should probably
pay us you know
we should we should someone should pay
us we should get there they
they can we're all with the show so i'll
pay you john wicks
right there this is yeah and this is
where the audio starts to fade down
[Music]
this is where i find out the credits
start to roll and it's like
film before a live studio audience well
maybe next week it will be
and we'll see you all there yay
bye everybody